welcome to this video has take off 85 91
come on i'm going to play the goon felt
for a change a student of mine recently
said he wanted to adopt this opening and
i had to confess that i have never
played it in tournament chess which is
really chill never not once so let's do
it at least in blitz row really I look
you one
rookie 10 funny looking one there's no
way to do this right Oh funny so if i go
d 5 or 6 e 5 for the supplying default
maybe and no this one okay okay i think
i'm going to take not quite not quite
sure so Bishop b5 TX Texas seven so I'm
probably here
he's got this pressure against you seven
is a little bit irritating cannot move
that freely yeah maybe something like
Luke c8 and then rooks is seven awesome
to cover e7 yeah whoopsie eight in all
night a five is an idea also try to
trade something here trade should favor
me in this position a little bit so he
allows me to take on d4 huh okay why I
don't know let's take it he gets his
seven if he wants but if I was hanging
and everything seems active now
I don't see you would move now I mean II
five hangsen and it will be an annoying
capture to face in fact both ruki 5n
Bishop g5 look awkward awkward to face
yeah what is he thinking about Bishop f7
some fantastic technical resources
yeah they dashed out everything
instantly and now it's time to check the
ruins of the position yeah this looks
decidedly wrong yeah we should be like
26 or something but it's not currently
yeah I don't see a direct punishment so
oops I'm going to take here I guess
don't don't see why not and now I guess
route cheeks my recon c8 is protected
and he cannot attack epsilon the second
time
ruchi 5 is something that I should keep
in mind attacking quite resigned okay
didn't come to that even um yeah okay
probably as soon as to go here then I
don't really I don't think I have
something fancy he can take check and
check has this resource so at the end I
would probably just take it I'm sorry
txt eggs and something like this and
this end game at this end cap his
winning for black but ok still an early
resign Bishop defy this is also weakness
besides white being a pawn down so how
did that happen it was it's an
interesting line with Bishop e3 I don't
really have any specific knowledge so I
just played kind of normal looking moves
and now I cannot take because of gyuki
one you know everything Hank since it's
not good so I went here yeah taking this
kind of thing is usually not very
promising for white yeah like this this
now those pawns remain very big even
though I'm a porn down typical Greenfeld
stuff and this happened and I went with
the captcha in 96 xe1 brooksy85 is
always a debatable move at this um give
white some some some options also
keeping my bishop on g7 looking now look
like looking bad questionable looking
for the right for better word than bad
yeah okay you went here and this just
gives away d for isn't it
hmm why isn't the engine giving this
move okay I just it gives the move but I
think it sings it things that is six
still very much okay for white okay i am
only i cannot take it that said that's
true that's true what is the computer
giving that's a funky line rook takes
Queen takes technique sticks and black
ass better a bit at least so the engine
wants to play this android change here
and rupture form and that's a very funny
line now this is supposed to be about
equal hmm I didn't see any of it but you
just took it and after that i'm probably
close to winning him yeah we get the
game position it's almost forced and
black really yappin he he has a big
advantage so he should have played 36
move which wasn't altogether that clear
okay well thanks for watching